kick some ass get the girl and try to
look doped are you doing
get underneath your face a little pride
what
three you wanted me back you could have
just asked me
a device that controls every military
satellite in the world
is fallen into the hands of four very
dangerous guys we need someone who can
move like them fight like them it's time
to be patriot there are no more Patriots
just rebel and tyrants so which are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team all right it comes Red Bulls
poster South I'm not gonna have clowns
watch my back who would you trust a good
the extreme rarely completely insane
which one I got what you need now that's
a team I can work with here we go
refreshing you actually know what you're
doing down there
yeah that's what she said Wow these case
of yours are the real kind of trouble
you have no idea what you're up against
whatever it is you're looking for you're
gonna come up short this is me you're
not making me breakfast in the water
we're willing to die to keep the world
safe how about you I live for this I
guess we're on the same team now you
ready to have some fun
I go long ago
let me simplify slee pick some ass get
the girl and try look dope why are you
doing
Danah feels good to be back
you